I've changed so much throughout my life
but I've tried not to have an identity
crisis as much throughout my life like
to tell myself being me was okay but
that me had a lot of changes and a lot
of growing up which like let me just get
right down to the fact that your mom was
taking you to nightclubs at 7 8 n years
old so was mine and I I don't for it now
would I do that as a parent no because
I'm different than that but the one
thing that really felt continually a lot
of pressure and anxiety that I could not
exactly identify at the time other then
if I don't keep working we were not
going to be able to support ourselves so
it there were high stakes it wasn't all
fun it was like there's work that has to
be done MH did you have that anxiety as
a kid I guess my response to that would
be in my obviously only from my own
experience I'm not a psychiatrist
but there's a re
growth means that you're moving from one
level of Education or
maturity to another I mean I just it I
developed a
little broken I think because I wasn't I
mean if you have drunk people falling
all over you and an adult and I'm eight
yep you know just put being put in
situations that are very unnatural I
loved what I was doing I mean I loved
music so I was torn so I loved I had
this passion for music and I thought
well I guess this is if you have a
passion for music then this is the way
you do it I think certain personalities
are not as capable of coping with it um
so I feel lucky that I you know was so
resilient but it I paid a price for it
you know um children are prisoners of
the of the adult environment and that's
how I felt what about when you're a
child that has to become an adult like I
got emancipated at 14 and got my first
apartment and got away from it I was in
an institution for two years and I was
like I have got to get away from this
and I've got to go find my path in
somewhere
else I had to take care of myself so
young right my biggest thing that I
would like to put to bed finally is to
stop being angry and disappointed and so
critical critical of the way I parented
myself but I had no other choice because
I had to you had this is the unfair
burden put on the
child that's not
right children shouldn't be burdened
with that like the way you're talking
right now I
I sure I had to parent myself I had to
parent my my kids I call them but you
know my siblings a lot from super young
age that was I don't blame myself
for I made a lot of mistakes I was a
terrible parent as at 10 I mean of
course I was a terrible parent at 10 so
I I'm like I must have been the worst
parent at 10 like how do you get the
kids in the
bath uh you know wash their hand their
clothes by hand make sure they're dry by
morning get them on the bus feed them da
D D D D how did of course I didn't do it
well I I sucked at it I mean it was
terrible I was a terrible parent you
were 22 when you became like a full
parent to three
siblings yeah well my parents died at
that point in the car accident exactly
and I'm so sorry no I I and thank you
for that I that was a
different type of parenting because now
there was nobody to blame cuz now
they're gone it's like I can't call them
up and go you know all of a sudden like
I'm responsible for making decisions
about my parents mortgage I didn't know
they had a mortgage I didn't know what
it was I didn't know anything about um
how they ran their business or debts or
or or insurance I had to learn overnight
I mean my parents died you know 3 days
later I'm in lawyers offices and and um
insurance company offices and and but
you did it you learned you checked the
Box you figured it out you Rose to the
occasion what else no choice thing the
no choice thing you know the no choice
this is what it is but this why it's so
good to to to plunge now in my life
because you don't always know what's on
the other side of the cliff right you
you don't always know how deep the water
is when you jump in whatever happens to
you um you will get to the other side
and when
you open your eyes you're like wow I
achieved something I what I actually
went through a fear threshold I passed a
fear threshold it doesn't even matter
what it is that you get on the other
side it's more about the fact that you
succeeded at you
know taking the leap
do you like having a residency and the
consistency of it because so much of our
life is like I don't know what city or
day or time I'll be like do you love the
consistency of a residency I love it I
love uh the consistency of the technical
side of it I'm I I you know I I produce
my shows and everything so it's
like I want to be able to count on the
sound the lights um the atmosphere the
environment how did you come up with
queen of me that I love it so much thank
you first of all um but queen of me just
take charge I'm in charge of myself I
can't speak for anybody else um but I do
take responsibility for what I think for
what I say for what I put out there yeah
and the message is take um charge of
yourself and your own behavior and
during Co it was for me um I'm I'm very
very lucky because I can turn to
songwriting so I can go and Escape
I can go to my therapist my guitar and
my microphone and my imagination that is
my Escape that is where I say no um
right now it's time to change your your
mood and one of the ways that you do
that is by being with your horses yeah
and I was
wondering can I meet your horses it's
time to hug a horse it is so time to hug
a
horse
[Music]
he